well I mean it'll be easy to find
yamimash but I mean come on wait why is
that why do I always get picked way no
cuz you're awful at games we all know
they got me hope yes you have thousands
of videos we know this to be true um
wait youyou push quite bit here no I
don't I'm just I'm saying there's quello
babies oh yeah Oh hmm just so you can oh
boy do you look stupid
oh well someone's a painting that's
official maybe I should van get out of
here like I lost focus
I've been working on that one I guess a
lot of suitcase is a lot of everything
it doesn't help my strategy is to become
something and then destroy every other
of that thing so they'll never know how
are you oh my he was a Kree come on give
us a kiss room is all on me wait how
many people are places just me and you
or is there actually just man
oh okay well you've passed by me a few
times like literally I'm in the main
hallway I'll give you that I am in the
main hallway yes a little glob glob glob
you were right the first time to assume
what I was get it um oh my god the
painting you get it you get it oh my god
Oh green now come and ask me
hahaha that is what I do
Jesus why I call that a win in my book
okay
now he knows for serious hey oh good oh
it's all y'all now hunting will be fine
oh oh it's not not it is it alright used
I'm sorry I'm sorry I made it quite
never mess that at me yeah just a bit
now she want to do another pinkie
promise I can't live without a bit of
how oh [ __ ] oh my gosh everything two
seconds well this should be easy
yeah I think I know where they are do
you oh that oh my god wait won't she I
didn't say uh I was the drink machine
behind it
Oh was it like really obvious
yeah was ever stuck in the other trades
machines oh don't use your grenades on
this map guys because it literally
vocally a yummy he's in the same room
the aam and I died yeah I don't know
which room that is I've been walking
with a load like this on tables and
stuff you know I think I'm gonna make
this a bit more fun I might let door on
the right there in there yep back here
you bottle bastard would you go where do
oh okay
I was like what y'all be are you still
there
did you what was that leo II just oh
goodness oh goodness
hang on hang on I gotta go to plan
something is something is changing while
you're busy doing whatever the hell
you're doing
that's okay I'll have a look in a minute
don't
oh I get it I get what you're doing
oh but that's thanks come on come on you
wouldn't believe it you won't believe
what's gonna happen
we won't un doing that we won't believe
it guys
what Heather what ok Yami is back right
I missing it's so much fun oh god it's
so fun uh right having so much fun
without Christ Internet got trafficking
tell me help me quick put a primary ok
ok bye ok
you bastard you hear kill me oh [ __ ]
just killed a oh good I'm out ok good
yeah user who died nope no God give you
an eye for now could you come be huh
hello no I'm so goddamn it
ok now whether I leave that that um that
problem Huh What Huh What devastated
what that was good huh that's good
that's good that's good what oh my god I
went right under your nose just you and
me minx
you and me oh no Amano you'd give me a
clue here I'm in the computer room No
zelich enough clue for you good enough
Claire are you gonna try to block up the
door again guys I'm 19 subscribers away
from 400,000 mm-hmm you had a hair fast
on this videos gonna be uploaded fat
three weeks off date sure I'm a couple
thousand from a million uh-oh I don't
feel so good anymore oh thanks hey guys
what are you doing
and Jesus is this worth the effort
yes is it really not really huh when you
go talk to your children someday will
you say that it's worth it oh they're so
good Yami's here to win again cuz I
always win
uh I have video proof to say that you do
not a lot of it by the way
oh gosh what I saw something yeah
Oh yummy yummy yummy quickly don't bad
word exact exact oh you dumb battered oh
I know where you are yeah
oh oh oh God
that one's a baby [ __ ] I just I'm just
saying that oh yeah I I didn't record
any of that you didn't know that five
cuz you Gail I am fudged if the baby
makes is this bad flashbacks of that
little logy mom that we played it is
yeah there's been a mistake
yeah it's the very odd thing
why would you think it was a herb in it
it's definitely much I think it's
something mark would pick yeah
definitely Oh God there were they are
the barricade this is been completely
trashed you don't know what happened in
this office that I'm not in hmm
interesting
it's office that I definitely am NOT in
well how are you doing today
[ __ ] hide that bottle how are you doing
a [ __ ] oh oh bottle
Isis hey no that's not you it's not you
so do you want to move or should I shoot
you unless you can't pick up the chairs
yeah yeah I know what to be next time
look yeah Marcus look at icicles prop oh
hula doll is definitely cheating on that
would be terribly cheating uh nice
nature last round anyway they might be
wonderful well they are they in here and
having a great time art that you love it
so you to these things right here my
neighbor of them you say the whole ramp
I'll just watch sorry whatever
wait Omar you in here too I am you are
Wow Wow was impressive to both of us so
many times it's impressive okay no in
this room the noise this reminisce
mark said you can't use the hula doll so
he must be in here either now he was
outside the room oh that's not possible
honest oh you you two are adorable
this is your torso daughter to assure
minute so don't shoot a grenade shoot a
kite you can observe your name should be
made is that you here in the corner
manga yeah Wow good what in the said
sugar and on tables okay mmm-hmm III
anything there in this room it's not the
rent the dinars for Emma see that okay
hey hey huh sure Oh
risky maneuver oh oh oh too late you're
done you're done you're never gonna buy
me never ever gonna find me
you're never in a billion years oh right
they're never gonna find me right
they're never gonna ever [ __ ] so mad oh
you're looking you wanna know the truth
okay I didn't know don't take a hit or
the truth I didn't learn it honestly I
didn't leave the computer room I don't
know what you saw but it wasn't me names
haha yamimash it I see I see that you
have 5% health left I do I'm very
shocked I'm glad one shot please just
tell me a clue and then I'll take a
one-shot risk you have walked by me and
you're very close very close oh the
house
okay I see that there's a way see one of
these I need five on the monument ice
just saw that you have 15% health he's
one of these he's one of these one shot
one oh yeah so few chances you pick you
touch me so many times I'm bad at this
game it's very easy for the